la tierra volvió a temblar en el sur de
Turquía la provincia de jaetai una de
las más afectadas por los devastadores
sismos de hace dos semanas se estremeció
de nuevo con dos terremotos de 6.4 y 5.8
grados que revivieron el pánico entre la
población
la gente entró en pánico fue un
terremoto muy fuerte había edificios
cerca de las carpas donde estábamos
entonces la gente quedó aislada de sus
familias
nuevos edificios destruidos sobre un
paisaje en ruinas centenares de heridos
y varios muertos en horas de la tarde
durante el temblor muchos se encontraban
en improvisadas tiendas de campaña donde
sobreviven a temperaturas bajo cero tras
haberlo perdido todo
el mundo empezó a gritar cuando se
produjo el terremoto la gente entró en
pánico y empezó a llorar a gritar y
estaban en estado de shock cuando
bajaron
si seguimos viviendo con este miedo y si
hay más réplicas nos quedaremos en
tiendas de campaña buscaremos Refugio
hasta que la situación
según las autoridades turcas para la
gestión de desastres se han registrado
más de 6.200 réplicas en los últimos 15
días y afirman que se seguirán sintiendo
Durante un año debido a la fuerza del
primer temblor
iba a pasar era predecible lo estábamos
esperando ahora esperamos más todo el
mundo debería estar más preparado para
esto
los terremotos en décadas dejan ya más
de 47 mil muertos en el sur de Turquía y
el noroeste de Siria y miles más sin
hogar mientras continúan buscando
supervivientes y las autoridades locales
inician las labores de reconstrucción
este lunes el secretario de estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken prometió
desde ankara la ayuda humanitaria por el
tiempo que sea necesario